the International Rescue effort is now
underway off the coast of Newfoundland
with vessels like the polar prints which
launched the submersible early on Sunday
morning now combing the area above the
wreck of the Titanic we know the
American Coast Guard they've had
aircraft up also scouring the area they
will pass that over to the Canadians at
first light and the Hope here is that
the crew of this submersible called
Titan that they have been able to make
it up to the surface and they are now
waiting on the surface for rescue that
is the hope there are other scenarios as
well more worrying scenarios that see
the vessel underneath the surface of the
North Atlantic or even lying on the
ocean floor and we know that the owners
of The Craft Ocean Gate are trying to
obtain a remote controlled vessel that
can operate at extreme depths the idea
that being that it is then able to
undertake some sort of rescue but we are
talking about four kilometers below the
surface that is where the wreck of the
Titanic lies four thousand meters below
and experts say it would be very very
difficult to to take one vessel and then
have it seal onto the hatch of another
and rescue the occupants on board very
difficult indeed however we do have five
human beings at fate unknown we know
that on this vessel Titan there are
basic Provisions oxygen and the like
enough for the next couple of days and
there are people here in Newfoundland
and the rest of Canada and in the United
States as well that will do whatever it
takes to try and get these people back
to safety